Florida shuttle boat captain is credited
with saving dozens of lives when a
massive fire broke out on board dramatic
video shows passengers jumping into the
freezing water as large flames and thick
smoke quickly surrounded the boat
yesterday 14 people were hurt and now we
received word one person has died the
boat was headed to a casino cruise just
off the coast near tampa vladimir
duthiers our streaming network cbsn is
following this story Vlad good morning
good morning the shuttle to the tropical
breeze Casino runs to and from the town
of Port Richey twice a day people on the
shores nearby said they noticed the boat
sounded different on Sunday just moments
before they saw a cloud of thick black
smoke billowing up from the ship's Stern
dramatic video taken from the shore
shows passengers jumping from the
flaming shuttle boat
police say the vessel had just started a
roughly three mile journey to an
offshore casino cruise when the captain
noticed something was wrong with the
engine next thing you know he started
seeing smoke and that's when he decided
to beach the boat up on the shore videos
taken by Lisa Schultz show flames
engulfing the boat in a matter of
minutes we were nervous that it was
gonna you know blow up do you could feel
the heat off of it she and her husband
rushed to help those forced into the
cold gulf water we had to get into the
water at one point and it was just
freezing and they were jumping off in
front of it we have a jump probably what
eight eight or ten feet to the water
passengers and crew that were able to
safely evacuate waited through 100 yards
of shallow water to reach emergency
personnel and nearby homeowners who had
come to help they were pulling clothes
out of their closets to bring out to us
to put on to keep warm
authorities say the decision to turn the
boat around
prevented a major disaster they were out
of his father if this could have been
but certainly different vending than
this a manager for the family-owned
tropical breeze casino says the company
lost its only shuttle boat in the fire
it's not clear what exactly caused the
fire onboard to start but heroism from
the captain and the folks on shore you
know amazing quick quick sinking blood
thank you